- J'ai tous les films
internationaux, là, placés par
pays : Angleterre, Aèèèèèèèèèèès
différents, tous entassés
dans son modeste local de
l'avenue Mont-Royal. Luc Major,
le propriétainininininininininis
parmi les derniers au Québec.
- Il en restait sept cet été,
qui a fermé récemment.
- Il tient bon par passion,
et aussi, parce que le local
seraient insuffisants
pour payer un loyer.
LUC MAJOR,
- C'est juste rentable, t'sais,
c'est...
(petit rire)
Juste assez poaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiat
profit, mais ça me donne même
pas le salaire minimum.
Mais j'aime mieux un emploi
moins qu'un emploi payant que
j'aimerais pas.
- Luc n'a plus d'employé et,
à l'exception du samedi,
seulement en soirée.
En 40 ans, les temps ont bien
changé.
- Si vous possédez
coûté en moyenne 900 $, et que
vous louez huit à dix casse
de films par semaine, vous êtes
un bon client d'un club vidéo.
la belle époque des clubs vidéo,
les années 2000 ont si
leur mort, avec les plateformes
de diffusion comme Netflix.
une douzaine de clients par soir
et connaît  p p p p par coeur.
- Mes prix sont pas chers
parce qu q q q q que je donne
une raison aux clients de sortir
de la maison. Moi, je charge...
taxes comprises.
- Je te remercie!
SUZY GAUTHIER, clienteetetetetes
en tant que tels, de pouvoir le,
prendre mon temps.
GÉRALD DOYON, client
puis de discuter avec lui
de toutes sortes de choses.
Ensuite "Snatch"...
Moi, je viens ici f f f f f f ,
en fin de compte.
- Mais sur la vitrine du
Cinoche, une pancarte à vendre.
L'hiver deeseseseseseseseseseses
lui proposent de moins en moins
de nouveautés.
- Il y a plein de films
qui nee e e e e e e e e e e e en
ai presque plus. Même
québécois, il y a des titres
qui ne sortent plus.- Sauf qu'as
sans offre, il senenenenenenant
à transformer la moitié de son
local en pet
- On fait un trou dans le mur,
le projectrrrrrrrrrrrrière...
- Ce qui lui permettrait,
il espère, de louer sess.s.s.s..
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.